Let's discuss the solution for our newest Iron Law quiz. We have 50 billion
instructions with different CPIs, so clearly we need to use our newest version
of the Iron Law of performance. Execution time is a sum of number of
instructions of a particular type times the CPI for the type.
In this case, it's 10 times 10 to the 9th,
which is 10 billion, times 4 for branches, plus 15 billion
times 2 for loads plus 5 billion times 3 for stores. And we said
the remaining instructions are integer add instructions. We have 30 billion
instructions here, so 20 billion are integer adds at CPF1. And all of that
times the clock cycle time, which is one over 4 times 10
to the 9th. Again, 4 gigahertz is the clock frequency.
The clock cycle time is 1 over that. Now, let's do the math here. This is
40 plus 30 plus 15 plus 20 times 10 to
the 9th divided by 4 times 10 to the 9th,
so 10 to the 9th can be crossed out and we get
105 over 4, which amounts to 26.25. So this
is how long it takes to run this 50 billion instructions
at 4 gigahertz, assuming these CPIs and this distribution of instructions.